m
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir un mot du
temps il a fait beau aujourd'hui et même
chaud dans de nombreuses régions du pays
c'est la première fois depuis le début
du printemps qu'il en était ainsi ceux
qui rentrent de congés de pâques auront
donc terminer leurs vacances en beauté
et beaucoup de gens retarderont j'en
suis sûr de quelques heures le retour
vers la ville attention aux
embouteillages jusqu'à c'est tard dans
la soirée bon et chaud disait jacques
marseille le soleil illuminait les
fontaines et il jouait avec les colonnes
de l'arc de triomphe et du palais de
justice aux marges imposante et au
dessin élégant à paris notre dame
resplendissait dans sa dentelle de
pierre et la scène calme et public
d'habitude semblait comme la crise dans
les jardins du louvre les premières
s'était assis paisiblement et chercher
de l'ombre qui lui dit qui l'eût cru il
ya seulement quelques jours derrière les
statuts tout temps cif comment
faisaient-ils brusquement si beau mais
toute médaille a son revers on a signalé
déjà les incendies de forêts dans le
gard et les avions canadair ont dû
intervenir ce qu'une chose rarissime en
appli venons en à la politique
internationale nouveau coup d'état en
afrique noire il se produit au liberia
le pays voisin d'ouest de la côte
d'ivoire un pays indépendant depuis 1847
le régime du président paul baert a été
renversée l'année dernière pour
corruption par la garde nationale
placée sous le commandement d'un sergent
chef samuel doe âgé de 28 ans et qui a
déclaré l'armée conduire un pays jusqu'à
celui ci prenne une décision pour son
avenir le sergent-chef sommet de doha
garantie qu'il ne toucherait pas aucun
étranger
la nouvelle équipe a été chaleureusement
accueilli par la population
monsieur tolbert tu étais un
pro-occidental
en tout cas après américain il a été tué
et sa femme emprisonnée on ne sait pas
encore grand chose d'autre
william tolbert à la tête du liberia
depuis 1971 actuel président de l'oiv
organisation de l'unité africaine un
homme qui en tout cas aura été jusqu'à
ces dernières années l'un des chefs
d'état les plus populaires d'afrique
à la tête d'un pays qui ne compte qu'un
million sept cent quatre-vingt mille
habitants le président tolbert c'est
pourtant heurtée depuis deux ans à une
position de plus en plus déterminés
occidentale plus particulièrement pro
américain le liberia est plus connue
dans le monde pour l'importance de sa
flotte commerciale comprenant notamment
874 pétrolier battant pavillon libérien
même si le pays ne possède qu'un seul
port à peine capable de recevoir deux
navires déjà des manifestations l'an
dernier contre l'augmentation du prix du
riz avaient fait une quarantaine de
morts dans les rues de monrovia ce soir
le seul communiqué publié par les forces
armées fait état de l'inefficacité du
président tolbert et de la corruption
générale du pays
la mort du président tolbert n'a pas
encore été confirmée officiellement mais
elle serait intervenu cette nuit au
moment où les forces armées envahissait
le palais présidentiel
à la havane livia actuellement près de
11000 cubain entassés dans les jardins
de l'ambassade du pérou et qui attendent
de pouvoir s'enfuir de leur pays le
gouvernement péruvien est prêt à
accorder immédiatement des visant un
millier d'entre eux et il prend des
dispositions pour envoyer de lima à cuba
des avions le plus vite possible afin de
les ramener ce milliers de gens à lima
mais de leur côté les autorités cubaines
n'avaient accordé à la date de ce matin
à ceux qui veulent partir que quelques
centaines de passeports et de permis de
sortie du territoire national
naturellement dans les jardins de
l'ambassade du pérou à la havane les
conditions sanitaires sont de plus en
plus difficile le cme comité
intergouvernemental pour les migrations
européennes sollicité par le pérou est
parlante à paris a offert d'installer
une antenne opérationnel à la havane
pour accélérer l'évacuation des gens
mais cuba pour le moment a refusé
l'offre quoi qu'il en soit ce brusque
flot de gens qui veulent quitter leur
pays cela a pu surprendre le peignant
internationales mais pas du tout seul et
cubains qui avaient déjà réussi à fuir
pour aller se réfugier reggae
et c'est une chose qui vient de très
loin c'est à dire que tous ceux qui ont
vécu à cuba depuis les débuts de
résolution savait que d'un moment à
l'autre ça devait se passer pourquoi
parce que du moment qu'on ferme les
frontières du moment où la liberté
d'expression
véritable authentique d'israël mène est
interdit de vraiment existé
bureaucratisme qui empêche
les rapports entre les peuples véritable
et les fonctionnaires ça provoque un
malaise qui grandit à mesure que le
temps passe donc déjà en 1965 il
couvrait une blague à la vanne que et si
on laissait la porte ouverte à la cub à
tout le monde partait sauf les membres
du gouvernement fidèle castelet veut que
les gens qui étaient absolument pour le
régime et qui appartenait à ce que l'on
connaît comme une nouvelle classe qui
représente à votre avis si ces 10000
cubain l'ambassade du pion c'est une
minorité parce qu'il ya des
manifestations pro castristes
aujourd'hui autonome hassan est attendu
il ya il y a à une grande partie d'une
petite fille dans ce palais nié qu'ils
aient encore pro castristes mais il ya
aussi une autre très très grande partie
l'île de cuba que tout en croyant à la
révolution se voit obliger de
l'aquitaine et puis il ya une autre
partie de cuba qu'elle soit absolument
contre la révolution depuis le début
donc il ya un échantillon de toutes
sortes de gens comment expliquez vous
que le gouvernement cubain acceptent de
laisser partir une telle masse de
réfugiés c'est contraire aux principes
socialistes oui mais est précisément je
crois que il s'agit peut-être d'une
erreur d'optique incroyants dire quand
on peut on laisse la porte ouverte
pendant un certain moment on croyait
peut-être qu'il avait 1000 1500
personnes comme a été dit dans un
journal le parisien et il ya dix mille
il ya peut-être bien plus parce que dans
la mesure où les cuvées retrouveront
aller à n'importe quelle ambassade pour
demander un visa sortie ils le feront et
le nom grandir le nombre grandit là et
vous le voulez vous qu'on le constate
hélas je crois peut-être et ça c'est un
bien pour le peuple cubain qu'il
s'agisse il s'agit d'une politique à
longue haleine c'est à dire si il s'agit
vraiment désolé liberté de voyage au
cuba c'est tant mieux pour tout le monde
en iran les ambassadeurs des deux pays
de la communauté européenne ont rendu
visite au président banny cendre comme
décidé aventure à lisbonne en exprimant
leur préoccupation au sujet des otages
et demandant la libération de ceux ci
sans s'associer pour le moment aux
décisions prises par les états unis
les neuf on laisser peser selon la fpp
une menace de sanctions contre l'iran
dès hier soir mais se dotera d avait
assuré aux ambassadeurs b9 que les
otages étaient en bonne santé cet après
midi l'iran a autorisé la croix rouge
internationale à rendre visite à tous
les otages mais vous le savez depuis 48
heures le président carter estime que
l'europe ne va pas assez loin à
l'encontre de l'iran et la presse
américaine se demande même si on peut
continuer à accorder le qualificatif d'
alliés aux européens voici les réactions
de monsieur bernard stasi président
délégué du cds coude et je crois qu'il
faut d'abord dire ceci la sphère des
otages de terence qu'un scandale un
scandale qui dure depuis plusieurs mois
il faut pas pour autant s'y habituer et
je vois qu'il faut le dénoncer avec
vigueur et puis c'est aussi une épreuve
une rude épreuve pour le peuple
américain et donc les alliés du peuple
américain les amis du peuple américain
doivent dans ces moments difficiles
lui manifester amitié solidarité et il
est possible qu'au cours de ces derniers
mois les européens les français n'est
pas toujours manifesté suffisamment
clairement l'amitié et la solidarité qui
est dû au peuple américain dans ces
moments mais l'alliance implique-t-elle
de prendre la même attitude cela dit
l'alliance et la fidélité ne sont pas
l'alignement je crois que précisément à
propos de cette affaire à propos du
malaise qui existe en ce moment dans les
relations entre les etats-unis et les
pays européens il faut réfléchir sur ce
que doivent être les relations au sein
de l'alliance atlantique
les européens veulent la protection dit
en substance le président carter refuges
les obligations d'alliance les
obligations de l'alliance est
effectivement de manifester la
solidarité mais c'est aussi la
concertation et à certain nombre de
mesures communes que l'on nous demande
de soutenir ont été prise de façon
unilatérale par les etats unis sans que
nous ayons été consultés est ce que la
solidarité atlantique mis en cause non
je crois que la solidarité atlantique
encore une fois implique que il y ait
des partenaires égaux pour nous
l'alliance atlantique à laquelle
aussonnaise ce vous le savez nous sommes
effectivement très attachés implique
qu'il y ait des partenaires égaux que
les etats-unis et les européens soient
des alliés à égalité de droits et de
devoirs ce qui implique je le disais
tout à l'heure la consultation la
concertation ceux qui appliquent aussi
que nous ayons une certaine indépendance
et et notamment je suis persuadé que
nous avons actuellement nous autres
européens et en particulier nous autres
français une grande partie à jouer
vis-à-vis du tiers-monde le tiers-monde
qui étaient choqués scandalisés par le
coup de kaboul qui considère désormais
que l'union soviétique est une puissance
impérialiste
eh bien nous ne pourrons profiter de cet
état d'esprit du tiers-monde nous
pourrons nous et avec le tiers-monde des
relations de coopération qui est
indispensable la fois pour des raisons
économiques et pour des raisons tenant à
l' équilibre du monde que si nous
prenons un peu de distance par rapport
aux etats-unis que ce nous
n'apparaissons pas au jeu du tiers-monde
comme étant des satellites des
inconditionnels des états unis et cela
je pense que les américains peuvent le
comprendre les américains disent aussi
que les européens ne veulent pas suivre
mais qui ne sont pas capables de
conduire est ce que l'europe est capable
de se conduire je crois que nous n'avons
dit à suivre ni à conduire que nous
avons les uns et les autres les
américains et les européens à nous
concerter et agir ensemble chacun avec
ses responsabilités et dans un esprit de
confiance est en tout cas il ne faut
jamais oublier que face à la menace que
représente l'expansionnisme soviétique
la puissance américaine quelles que
soient les erreurs les faiblesses les
maladresses de la politique américaine
la puissance américaine nous protège
protège nos libertés est donc
indispensable de tout faire pour
rétablir le climat de confiance par les
erreurs et maladresses c'est une
maladresse américaine une maladresse du
président carter l'est le présent carter
en ce moment est celui où est-ce le
candidat qui conduit la politique on a
parfois le sentiment que les
fluctuations de la politique américaine
tantôt le président souffle le chaud et
anton le froid tantôt riz il prédit un
grand bâton et tantôt elle envoie une
lettre affectueuse à l'ayatollah a bien
agi sentiment que ces fluctuations
tiennent dans une certaine mesure à des
considérations électoralistes dans
lesquels ne vont pas entrer que ne vont
pas nous autres à prendre en compte au
nom tant aux jeux olympiques sans
quitter la politique le vice président
des états unis monsieur mambe elle a
estimé que le vote des délégués du
comité olympique des états-unis vote qui
doit intervenir ce soir qui m'a
peut-être déjà intervenue il ya une
minute ou deux sera en faveur du
boycottage des jeux de mots sont
demandés par le président carter après
l'entrée des troupes soviétiques en
afghanistan fin décembre le
vice-président modèles de wc vrai c'est
lui-même au comité américain réunies à
colorado springs disant en substance
votre vote a une importance considérable
non seulement pour les athlètes à qui il
est demandé attrayant sacrifices mais
pour tous les américains et les pays
civilisés nous sommes tous responsables
puisqu'il faut faire passer l'intérêt de
notre pays avant tout autre est la
question que vous devez tranchée est
essentiel pour le futur du monde libre
le comité olympique avait en théorie
jusqu'au 24 mai pour accepter ou refuser
l'invitation des organisateurs des jeux
de moscow et ses dirigeants espérer que
d'ici cette date limite là les
soviétiques changerai peut être bâtie
plus en afghanistan
c'est ce qu'avait surtout d'espérer le
président du comité américain mais ce
qu'est née finalement il n'aura pas été
possible d'atteindre devant l'assistance
de la maison blanche en somme les
américains retourne 14 ans après le
boycottage que les soviétiques leur
avait infligé en 1966 en annulant cette
année là le match athlétisme états unis
urss pologne prévue à barclays en
californie à cette époque les pays
socialistes reprocher deux américains
rappelons le les premières interventions
au nord vietnam des bombardiers
stratégiques b52 qui avaient coupé la
piste hô chi minh mais le boycott des
jeux de moscou ne signifie pas forcément
la fin du mouvement olympique
international les prochains jours sont
prévus pour 1984 à los angelès aux états
unis et la grande cité californienne se
prépare comme vous ne verrez dendre
portage que vous propose claude bègue
los angeles ville olympique c'était en
1932 on avait découvert ici l'or le
pétrole et le soleil d'hollywood clark
gable fred astaire et les marques podz
on était aussi en pleine dépression
économique
les jeux à peine terminée quelques
passionnés dévoré par la flamme
olympique fondettes une association et
juré de faire revenir les jeux à los
angeles parmi eux bill schrader qui a
aussi créé ce musée et qui cinquante ans
plus tard voit son travail récompensé il
a vu les jeux de 32 et s'est battu pour
ceux de 84
je suis très fier d'avoir été en 1937 un
des fondateurs du comité pour le retour
des jeux olympiques ils reviendront aux
84 et j'y serai
pour une fois en effet les californiens
n'ont pas pensé big grands depuis quinze
ans que la ville est régulièrement
candidate à l'organisation des jeux tout
a déjà été construits et utilisés
le colisée où ont eu lieu les épreuves
il ya 50 ans sera réaménagé en
particulier pour la presse il n'y avait
pas de télévision en 32 sur les
vingt-et-une installations sportives
qu'utiliseront les concurrents 19 existe
déjà on ne construira pratiquement rien
los angeles qui avait été la première
ville à bâtir un village olympique sera
la première à n'en pas construire les
athlètes logeront dans les cités
universitaires où ils trouveront aussi
des installations et équipements pour
s'entraîner ucla et la meilleure
université sportive des états unis aux
pays du gigantisme on va retrouver une
dimension humaine à commencer par le
comité organisateur 17 personnes
seulement 400 à montréal dirigé par un
businessman
les jeux de los angeles ne seront pas un
goût on fera au contraire du bénéfice si
les olympiades existe encore et c'est la
question en décidant le boycott de
moscou le président carter a peut être
tué les jeux olympiques
ont survécu jusqu'à présent à des crises
plus importante de guerre mondiale par
exemple les athlètes du monde entier
veulent la poursuite des jeux olympiques
est en fait nous ne savons pas encore ce
qui va se passer pour ceux de moscou
si les américaines ne vont pas moscou on
peut penser que les russes ne viendront
pas à los angeles
ils ont déjà fait savoir qu'il ne ferait
pas cela sans même que nous leur ayons
demandé
publiquement ils ont déclaré qu'ils ne
passeront pas les jeux de los angeles
ils ne le font pas pour une bonne raison
une raisons de propagande en sport ils
sont les meilleurs
vous continuerez s'en tenir compris les
menaces
nous continuons mais pas sans ignorer la
menace nous tenons compte des problèmes
internationaux et politiques qui
entourent les jeux olympiques et nous
tenons compte aussi de l'inflation
deux raisons nous avons décidé d'être
prêts très vite et ne seront prêts en
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des jeux le comité est une association
privée il a passé avec nbc un des géants
de la télévision le plus gros contrat
encore de l'histoire du sport et le
label fournisseur officiel des jeux
olympiques a été vendus à des dizaines
de sociétés avec quatre ans d'avancé les
deux tiers du financement de l'opération
sont déjà assurés peter hubert ott va de
l'avant refusant d'écouter les menaces
car ronald reagan candidat républicain à
la présidence des états unis est aussi
partisans du boycott de moscou et
propose que les jeux se tiennent dans
l'avenir définitivement en grèce
pourtant si les américains boycott
moscou ils auront un représentant peter
hubert ott qui devra recevoir à la
cérémonie de clôture la flamme des
russes si le président carter le lui
interdit et si la flamme n'est pas
transmise alors ce sera effectivement la
fin des jeux
et que pense à propos des jeux
olympiques les appels princes à huis
clos jacques rousseau champion d'europe
de saut à bord du air et sélectionnés
français pour les jeux olympiques les
jeux olympiques sans les américains
qu'est ce que ça peut représenter pour
les athlètes de haute compétition comme
vous personnellement je dirais que les
jeux olympiques sans les américains
iront en boitillant il manquera ce sera
vraiment une grosse romande pour le
sport enfin en général du fait que les
américains sont une des toutes premières
nations sportives et que sans eux
il est en plus que beaucoup de pays
suivront effectivement ses amis qui ne
viennent pas il y aura pas mal dit deux
pays
notamment l'angleterre certainement et
puis le canada et puis certains autres
qui ne viendront pas et ils n'ont plus à
ce moment alors que nous n'y sommes pas
encore chaque pays va prendre sa
décision dans les semaines qui viennent
mapaq on peut toujours supposer que ce
que vous dites et cc c'est l'hypothèse
la plus vraisemblable
oui les etats-unis se retirant des jeux
jacques rousseau les adeptes français
souhaitent ils toujours participer à ces
jeux olympiques quel est votre sentiment
à ce sujet sans qu'ils ont de vos
camarades aussi
il est difficile quand même de donner
une opinion générale enfin selon ce que
j'ai pu recueillir comme information de
la part de mes 2 les autres amis je
pense que de façon juste d'une manière
générale ils sont et sont décidés à y
aller faut se mettre à leur place aussi
il faut se mettre à notre place même je
dirais c'est qu'il ya une quand même une
préparation qui est fait en fonction des
jeux est toujours très difficile de
passer à côté d'une occasion comme
celle-là mais à mon avis personnel
enfin personnellement ça n'intéressera
pas d'aller aux jeux
s'il ressembler à une sport tas qui est
par exemple c'est à dire sans les
athlètes de l'ouest a simplement que les
pays
alors si ça vous intéresserait pas
quelles seraient vos motivations pour y
aller quand même les motivations pour
gagner de toute façon des motivations de
rester les mêmes tout ce qui peut se
passer politiquement autour des jeux
olympiques ne doivent pas en tan est
aucunement la motivation d'un athlète je
ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous il n'est tout de même pas possible
que les athlètes disent non sautons 1
centimètres plus haut que les autres on
voit centimètres plus loin nous pouvons
1 10e de seconde plus vite nous lançons
un mètre plus loin le poids le discours
javelot par conséquent nous nous
extrayons nous mêmes des questions de
politique internationale et nous avons
notre déontologie propre nous ne tenons
pas compte de la situation
internationale est-ce que vous pensez
que les athlètes est ce que les sportifs
peuvent se permettre quand je vois ce
que vous voulez dire enfin il est hors
de question d'extraire quoi que ce soit
il est évident que les jeux olympiques
ne tiennent qu'à cause de la politique
c'est essentiellement politique à mon
avis on est sans voix il n'y avait pas
de je ne vois pas comment ils ont pu
atteindre ce niveau de popularité enfin
au niveau des peuples sans une
implication politique mais le fait est
sekondi sportif
et on a des obligations envers ce que
l'on fait n'est pas question de laisser
tomber comme cela des années
d'entraînement pour des opinions
politiques ou jeudi à même de
politiciens ceci étant
personnellement je me range du côté de
l'as de la décision du comité olympique
français ce qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec l'édition politique
puisse y avoir des gens comme fera comme
décidera le comité politique lancée
ainsi vous ferez j'espère oui j'espère
qu'ils seront
qu'il faille retenir l'hypothèse
où l'on donnerait à chaque athlète la
possibilité d'aller ou de ne pas aller
selon sa propre conscience selon sa
conception des choses ce serait une très
bonne chose mais est ce que ce sera
possible à la niche au mondial
votre sentiment d'athlètes maintenant
comment voyez-vous l'avenir des jeux
olympiques los angelès d'abord je pense
que cette année il veut à moins
d'hypocrisie en ce qui concerne les jeux
olympiques parce que je pense que depuis
pratiquement depuis la cria la nouvelle
création de zones épique
ils n'ont survécu que grâce à la
commandite grâce à une certaine forme
d'hypocrisie et qu'actuellement tout
cela il est complètement déblayer et
qu'il faudrait une restructuration
pratiquement de toutes les règles
olympique de façon d adapter à la vie
actuelle et c'est leur seul à mon avis
c'est leur seule chance de survivre il
faut donc qu'il serait mieux qu'ils
soient novices je crois que c'est ce
dont souffrait d'un mal à bien merci
jacques rousseau à propos des risques
nous parlons politique de visas certain
temps à propos des risques la situation
internationale un livre vient de sortir
dont le père est l'ancien président des
états unis richard nixon en france et
porte le titre la vraie guerre paru chez
albin michel monsieur nixon se montre
pessimiste pour son pays dont il accuse
des dirigeants de faiblesse de démission
l'ancien président sera en direct
l'invité d'honneur d'antenne de midi
l'indien 8 pts c'est à dire le lundi 21
afrique france nous sommes plus que
jamais décidés à dire non à l'admission
de l'espagne dans le marché commun a
déclaré à montpellier monsieur bernard
pons secrétaire général du rpr lors d'un
congrès régional de son mouvement ce
qu'il faut affirme monsieur bernard pons
c'est que les neuf partenaires de
l'europe se mettent autour d'une table
pour remettre de l'ordre dans le marché
commun que madame thatcher calme ses
humeurs et que le gouvernement français
soit fait en mer les courses au large de
nombreuses cette année en france la
saison a débuté avec la semaine nautique
internationale
de marseille c'était l'occasion de
s'interroger sur les questions de
sécurité un maire qui avec le
développement très fort de la plaisance
et la multiplication des compétitions
peuvent recettes années 1980 encore une
fois se pose est
la mère n'a pas été tendre pour les
bateaux de course au large les
différentes transatlantique ou des
courses comme le fastnet ont payé un
lourd tribut à la mer en hommes et en
bateau à marseille la disparition d'un
voilier il ya deux ans au cours d'une
compétition pèse encore sur les esprits
et de coups de vent qui s'est produit
vendredi au début d'une épreuve a fait
une nouvelle fois réfléchir sur le
problème de la sécurité est amené les
organisateurs à constater un curieux
paradoxe des bateaux de moins affûté
plus tranquille qu'en ce moment peu ce
qu'on appelait la course croisière ont
régaté beaucoup ont abandonné mais il ya
eu aucun dégât et tous ont appris et un
certain nombre ont été classés alors que
les bateaux de pointe on ne les a pas
fait courir
la sagesse des organisateurs est des
compétiteurs on fait qu'il n'y a pas eu
finalement de casse de matériel au cours
de ce coup de vent mais le fait que des
bateaux ne soient pas toujours capables
d'affronter tous les types de temps sans
risque amène à se poser des questions la
première sur les bateaux avec un
spécialiste en la matière michelle
mendes savez prototype ce sont des
lattes effectivement extrêmement léger
ce sont des bateaux qui demande beaucoup
de mises au point beaucoup de réglages
qui souvent ne sont pas tout à fait prêt
d'ailleurs au moment du départ de la
course parce qu'ils ont été mis à l'eau
à peine quelques heures avant et tout ça
évidemment à agir en défaveur de ce type
de bateau lorsqu'il s'agit d'affronter
des temps comme celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui
la deuxième ensuite sous forme de mise
au point sur le rôle des propriétaires
de bateaux chaque propriétaire du bateau
chaque responsable de l'auto doit savoir
si le bateau est en état si les voilures
est bonne si le mât est bon et si le
matériel s'est couvert et là si
l'équipage est capable c'est n'est pas
capable il ne prend pas le départ où il
abandonne ce que tout à fait légitime
sinon il assume son entière
responsabilité
mais le seul but de la compétition c'est
de gagner et dans ce type de compétition
plus un bateau et léger plus il a de
chances d'aller vite donc les bateaux
sont de plus en plus les et pour faire
léger et solide il faut une qualité de
construction irréprochable
ce qui il faut bien le dire n'est pas
toujours le cas alors la solution l'est
sans doute dont une évolution de
l'architecturé de la construction navale
vers des techniques du modèle si on
s'inspire l'aéronautique on arrivera à
des légèretés beaucoup plus grande
l'avoine n'a pas les moyens n'a pas
la volonté probablement de faire
on pourra donc toujours améliorer la
solidité des bateaux donné aux hommes
une meilleure connaissance de la mer
renforcé les mesures de sécurité et cela
n'empêchera jamais les fortunes de mer
de frapper à un moment ou un autre il ne
s'agit pas alors d'accuser ou de
chercher des responsables dans un
accident de la mer mais plutôt d'en
tirer les leçons comme les anglais ont
su si bien le faire après le drame du
fastnet
à notre époque industrialisés où la
notion de rendement est devenue
primordiale les travailleurs cultive
encore prendre le temps d'avoir une vie
personnelle tel sera l'un des thèmes
après demain lundi de l'émission de la
rédaction d'antenne de questions tant
présenté par une berio le temps de vivre
nous irons entre autres dans une chaîne
de montage à pau où les ouvrières
doivent répéter le même geste de 800
voix par jour et pour pouvoir quitter un
instant la chaîne il leur faut une
autorisation spéciale alors comment
aménager deux temps de travail pour un
faire le temps de vivre et pour que les
mères de famille par exemple puisse un
peu mieux profiter de leurs enfants
20h35 lundi sur antenne 2 question de
temps cyclisme- demain c'est
paris-roubaix il y a deux favoris moser
l'italien qui a déjà gagné la course
deux fois hergé vlaeminck le belge
quatre fois vainqueur c'est hardcore
parmi les axes adhère la nouvelle
vedette française duclos lassalle et
bernard hinault qui pour le moment n'a
jamais gagné paris roubaix jean paul
ollivier les a rencontré l'un et l'autre
cette semaine au tour cycliste du tarn
et oui ça peut étonner les gens qui
connaissent super besse dino il n'a
encore jamais gagné
mais disons que paris roubaix je pense
que c'est une cause de mes cordes violon
gabarit et la puissance que je détiens
même très en ce moment vu l'enfant puis
l'année dernière j'ai fait une bonne
échappée nice paris roubaix cette année
j'ai changé ma façon de courir je vais
essayer de couvrir les costauds qu'on me
moser à ce développement qui a essayé de
les filets jusqu'aux actions jusqu'à la
fin c'est paris-roubaix trois un peu
dans la tête vu ma performance de
l'impasse et faire des saints monde sur
les pavés échapper les ans que je vais
filets ce sera toujours les mêmes moser
race développement que je pense que ça
sera le trio de dix finales
vous voyez un petit peu comment la
course peut se décider mais je pense
qu'il faut pas du tout faire aucun
effort jusqu'à valentré de pavés puis
dès l'entrée des preuves et être avec
eux
de toute façon le vainqueur de paris
roubaix est un garçon en forme alors
vous pouvez triomphe est finalement très
en fait j'ai dit jamais parce que il ya
toujours des surprises à sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer dans la course on
peut avoir des pépins on peut voir des
chutes gagner j'espère pour moi mon but
ce serait leur entraîneur les premiers
ou d'aller signer et faire une belle
place
quant à bernard hinault vous ne l'avez
encore jamais vu ainsi pour décharger le
soigneur de son équipe il a proposé
spontanément ses services pour masser
son coéquipier le guide pense-t-il à la
reconversion nul ne peut l'affirmer ce
qu'il convenait de lui demander en tout
cas c'est de nous parler de sa forme
physique avant paris roubaix
je pense que la veille de paris roubaix
l ai pas fait un maximum maximum est
très bonnes conditions à l'année vous
dirai jamais une possibilité si on
savait à peu près à quel moment ça
allait venir
attendez un peu près le silence et celui
du tiff on arrive toujours allé un peu
trop paniqué tout surtout le rendre
rendu une réparation passionnel paris
roubaix n'est pourtant pas une course
comme les autres il faut l'aborder quand
même avec une certaine préparation vous
n'avez pas peur d'être un petit peu
limité malgré tout prêts tout dépend du
temps je pense que si 20 ans veut très
clémente comme on a actuellement autour
du tarn il est possible que
l'on soit bien d'interviewer un héros
pas que moi je frappe il est plus
courant chez nous qui ont quand même la
possibilité d'être encore là dans le
final
on dit généralement que dans paris
roubaix il faut des hommes des hommes
type pour ce genre de parcours vous vous
dit que vous êtes un petit peu léger sur
les pavés
je suis un peu léger peut-être mais
je crois que quand on a la volonté on
peut y arriver je crois que l'état de
tour de france qu'on arrivait sur les
pavés approuvait la même que je pouvais
le faire les moments où quand je suis
entré minutes entre très bonnes
conditions
moser l'avantagent du poids
ne me rase aussi bien que la mine ne
faut quand même pas mal de courses en
belgique sur les pavés ce qui fait
qu'ils sont quand même plus à l'aise que
moi est ce que vous considérez que tant
que vous n'avez pas gagné paris roubaix
vous n'avez pas le palmarès suffisamment
étoffé pour vous dire un véritable
champion moi j'ai jamais ligue des
champions j'ai dis surtout que j'étais
un coureur cycliste qui fait de son
métier le mieux possible
ne court pas après les résultats
spécialement pour dire j'ai été telle et
telle course pour le reste je crois que
c'est parra c'est pas ma devise si un
jour j'ai lu j'ai la chance de pouvoir
le gagner tant mieux
le tiercé demain à longchamp a eu lieu
dans le prix de la télévision un nombre
particulièrement sympathique distance
assez courtes 1850 mètres au départ 19
poulains et pouliches qui viennent juste
de prendre leurs trois ans ils sont donc
encore peu connu il est difficile
d'apprécier exactement leur chance c'est
dont la bouteille à l'encré pierrette
brès a choisi marc oui john le set qui
n'a jamais gagné mais qui est toujours
et perd non seulement un excellent
cheval first american 2 6 mais il n'a
pas encore fait sa rentrée il peut
manquer de travail rosie 'future' de
14,5 pour cinq fois à l'arrivée même le
3 qui reste sur une victoire et qui peut
encore progresser saint géran le 13 en
progrès constant et touquet thauvin
leucate mal berry le 16
roderick le 12 enfin non français danse
comme il y avait en musique le célèbre
groupe des six fois ci en matière de
danse le groupe des huit des maîtres qui
se sont donné pour tâche de promouvoir
leur art à leur appel et pour la dixième
année consécutive 350 professeur de
danse exerçant dans les écoles et les
académies particulières sont venus de
l'europe entière à paris pour se mettre
en jambes pour se rafraîchir leur
technique auprès des meilleurs
spécialistes du monde paris serait-il
redevenu un des haut-lieux
internationaux de la danse et bien à
cette question voici la réponse proposée
par huit personnes
est-ce que la technique est méritée mais
quelque chose de particulier que
l'européen aura
peut-être quand j'étais quand je danse
je danse avec les forces entre man et
j'ai poussé poussé crise et russes pour
le vitesse arriver quand j'oublie et
tout le monde en français fait pas ça
pour le moment oui mais à
j'espère avec un auteur à 2 ans 3 1 est
il arrivé exactement comme moi
parra mais cela dit
boudet manderen tire
ça excellent n'y prends trois
journées
dida quand vous prenez
ou pas
j'ai encore deux dates à retenir
beaucoup de le 4
mars le march 6 vienne qui attendait les
fans archers présents
et vous vous sentez obligé de venir au
russian régulièrement des stages de
rentrer vite
pour me recycler pour avoir l'occasion
de travailler avec des professeurs
internationaux vous pensez que de temps
en temps dans son petit coin ont fini
par 100 kg unasur
des claquettes surprise que celui
anglais vous êtes espagnol pourquoi
voulez vous apprendra à paris car en
espagne a pas vraiment de la fission
claquettes tandis qu'à londres et à
paris c'est le paradis des claquettes
grille en espagne par leurs auteurs
et c'est à les laisser tomber la journée
insensible et laisser aller la jambe
à
m
j'ai étudié à molsheim 12 joueuses
études pédagogiques licra graphique au
bolchoï pour
mais en matière de danse classique on
peut vraiment pas se passer de virus ou
s'est pas passé de bus là mais je pense
oui on en manquant époque de sable
clients professeur de france il s'en
allèrent aussi il là ils sont plantés la
danse
français classique la nation ça marche
dans l'autre il a maintenant ça marche
on recense maintenant ça commence un peu
dans égalitaire
météo les températures resteront
agréables de ma sur l'ensemble du pays
mais les nuages deviendront plus
abondants sur la moitié ouest ainsi que
près du golfe du lion quelques pluies
passagères son possible mais non
certaine dès le matin sur la bretagne à
la vendée en fin de journée elle
pourrait gagner la normandie et
l'aquitaine
les vins de sud se renforceront et
quelques rafales sont possibles près de
l'atlantique et de la manche occidental
tout à l'heure en fin de soirée vous
avez rendez vous avec gérard holtz qui
vous donnera les dernières informations
de la journée à demain si vous le voulez
bien bonne soirée bonsoir